Geneviève darrieussec la Ministre
chargée des personnes handicapées était
en déplacement en Indre-et-Loire
aujourd'hui était prévu notamment la
visite du Centre de Ressources Autisme
ainsi que de la plateforme d'orientation
et de coordination pour les troubles du
neurodéveloppement au CHRU de Tours il
s'agit d'un des cinq établissements
spécialisés dans le domaine à être
classé centre d'excellence en France il
regroupe des activités de recherche de
diagnostics d'enseignement de formation
et de soins des familles viennent
parfois de l'étranger pour y solliciter
un diagnostic on a une expertise si vous
voulez partager aussi par bien sûr
d'autres centres mais quand même qui est
très approfondie dans tout ce qu'on
appelle l'analyse fonctionnelle donc
vraiment les évaluations très fines sur
le développement cognitif sur le
développement langagier sensori moteur
de l'enfant ou de la question de y
a-t-il un autisme ou pas on peut
vraiment préciser un profil très
individuel de l'enfant dans ces domaines
et du coup ça ça permet de définir des
programmes très individualisés aussi
dans les dans tout ce qui est
intervention et rééducation
historiquement ce centre touranjo a été
le premier site de ce type développé en
France il y a 50 ans aujourd'hui un
exemple à suivre selon le gouvernement
nous sommes en train de terminer
l'écriture de la nouvelle stratégie
autiste qui va être présentée dans
quelques semaines par le Président de la
République et quand on voit ici
ce centre très complet entre la
recherche l'accueil des familles les
diagnostics la prise en charge les
l'interlations avec l'école avec le
monde d'extérieur qu'on a vraiment un
centre complet et je crois que c'est
effectivement un très très bon modèle de
réussite
en ce moment le centre travaille aussi à
développer d'autres programmes de
recherche notamment sur le
vieillissement des personnes autistes et
également sur les diagnostics très
précoces